we're asked to simplify eight plus five
times four - and then in parentheses 6
plus 10 divided by 2 plus 44 whenever
you see some type of crazy expression
like this where you have parentheses in
addition and subtraction and division
you always want to keep the order of
operations in mind and let me write them
down over here so when you're doing
order of operations or really when
you're evaluating any expression you
should have this in the top of your or
in kind of the front of your brain is
that the top priority goes to
parentheses parentheses 4 n parentheses
and those are these little brackets over
here however you want to call them those
are the parentheses right there that
gets top priority then after that you
want to worry about exponents there are
no exponents in this expression but I'll
just write it down just for future
reference exponents one way I like to
think about it is parentheses that
always takes top priority but then after
that we go in descending order or I
guess we should say in well yeah in
descending order of how kind of fast
that computation is and when I say fast
how fast it grows when I take something
to an exponent when I'm taking something
to a power it grows really fast then it
grows a little bit slower or shrinks a
little bit slower if I multiply or
divide so that comes next multiply or
divide multiplication division comes
next and then last of all comes addition
and subtraction so these are kind of the
slowest operations this is a little bit
faster this is the fastest operation and
then the parentheses just no matter what
always take priority so let's apply it
over here let me rewrite this whole
expression so it's eight plus five times
four minus in parentheses six plus 10
divided by two plus forty four so we're
going to want to do the parentheses
first we have parentheses there and
there now this parentheses is pretty
straightforward well inside the
parentheses that's already evaluated so
we could really just view this as five
times four so let's just evaluate that
right from the get-go so this is going
to result in a
Plus and really when we're evaluating
the parentheses if you evaluate this
parentheses you literally just get five
and then you evaluate that parentheses
you were to just get four and then
they're next to each other so you
multiply them so five times four is
twenty - let me stay consistent with the
colors - now let me write the next
parenthesis right there and then inside
of it we evaluate this first so let me
close the parentheses right there and
then we have plus forty four plus forty
four so what is this thing right here
evaluate to this thing inside the
parentheses well you might be tempted to
say well let me just go left to right
six plus ten is is 16 and then divide by
two and you would get eight but remember
order of operations division takes
priority over addition so you actually
want to do the division first and we can
actually write it here like this you
could imagine putting some more
parentheses let me do that same purple
you could imagine putting some more
parentheses right here to really
emphasize the fact that you're going to
do the division first so 10 divided by 2
is 5 so this will result in 6 plus 10
divided by 2 is 5 6 plus 5 well we still
have to evaluate this parentheses so
this results with 6 plus 5
well that's 11 so we're left with 20 let
me write it all down again we're left
with 8 plus 20 minus 6 plus 5 which is
11 plus 44 and now that we have
everything at this level of operations
we can just go left to right
so 8 plus 20 is 28 so you could view
this as 28 minus 11 plus 44 28 minus 11
28 minus 10 would be 18 so this is going
to be 17 it's going to be 17 plus 44 and
then 17 plus 44 I'll scroll down a
little bit 17 plus 44 7 plus 44 would be
51 so there's going to be 61 so this is
going to be equal to 61 and we're done